so Anlage N nicht selbständige Arbeit
gehrt
DAH so
fertig
nein ja bitte Gott sind sie der Josef
haberlander ja warum ja wunderbar dann
können wir ja gleich
loslegen ich bin dieas
hat ihn ihre Tochter nicht Bescheid
gegeben wegen was wegen dem
enkelworkshop sie hat sie bei uns
angemeldet schon wieder so ein
esoterikrampf nein nein nicht Engel
Enkel kann es sein dass sie sich ein
Enkelkind wünschen ja schon aber s hen
dass die sabrina ist die noch nicht die
Sabrina möchte erstmal wissen ob sie
überhaupt bereit sind für ein Enkelkind
weil wenn sie ein Kind be kommt dann
werden sie recht oft darauf aufpassen
müssen ob ich bereit bin für enkelk die
ist ja gut richten sie ja aus ich habe
schon mal Kind aufgezogen und zwar die
Sabrina und aus der ist ab was worden
also mehr oder weniger ja aber Kind ist
nicht gleich Enkelkind ach so sind die
heute anders sind die jetzt heute mit
ehantrieb und kriegen die nur noch
vegane Muttermilch her haberlander ein
bisschen mehr Ernst bei der Sache bitte
ja also wenn Sie hier durch den brasseln
dann überlegt sich das ihre Tochter noch
mal
also okay machen wir's wir machen jetzt
erstmal den Hörtest ich hö nicht
schlecht noch
nicht Jast du ir geht um
Kind ja spinst du iremint es geht um
Kinder und nicht um ein Düsenjäger ja
das ist ja fast das gleiche ne
120 Dezibel ah ja und S ungefähr die
gleichen Dreckschleudern bitte niich ja
da werden sie aber noch ordentlich üben
müssen also ich bin bereit für Enkelkind
das wird sich noch herausstellen wir
haben ja noch ein paar Aufgaben vor uns
stellen Sie sich vor Ihr en ist bereits
ein Kleinkind und läuft bei ihnen durch
die Wohnung schön
ungefähr
so bitte Kinder anschrei und ich bin
jetzt das Kind die kleine Jasmin okay du
Kind diein da wird der Opi ganz ganz
traurig wenn du seine Sachen uminander
schmeiße
tust ich will aber wo die großen
Elefanten spazieren gehen ohne sich zu
stoßen rechts Bäume linksä und da
zwischen Zwischenräume wo die großen
Elefanten spazieren gehen
sto du saufrat jetzt wenn nicht gleich
aufst dann kriegst Du von mir eine
mordstrum schokolad Mast schokoladrum
schokolad apropos schokolad angenommen
die Mama hat ihn eine Liste gegeben mit
Dingen die sie zu beachten haben was
machen sie damit Opa Achtung kein Zucker
keine
Babysprache keine Drohungen keine bösen
Wörter und kein
Fernsehen so
scheiße
Schmetterling was mal auf du
saubeutel also jetzt wenn du ganzer
ganzer braves mäi bist dann darfst du
beim Opa den ganzen Tag Fernseh schauen
und so vi Gummibärli essen wie du willst
h magst du
das und was ist mit der Mama
na ja der S mal einfach nichts das ist
unser Geheimnis ganz ganz großes
opiehrenwort Herr halander ich
gratuliere sie haben bestanden sie sind
jetzt offiziell Opa geeignet ja toll tja
Eltern müssen erziehen Großeltern
verwöhnen ja die Kinder müssen ja auch
mal die Sau rauslassen Süßigkeiten
Fernsehen gammeln aber das sagen wir vom
Enkel Workshop den Eltern natürlich
nicht
also ich sag ihrer Tochter Bescheid sie
kann loslegen ja einen schönen Tag noch
herzlichen
Glückwunsch die die die die Grünen die
mag ich am
[Gelächter]
liebsten hallo hallo
das mit die Enkel ich überleg's mir
vielleicht doch noch
mal